سنواصل تطوير وتعزيز
قواتنا المسلحة ، مع مراعاة
التهديدات والمخاطر العسكرية المحتملة
اساس الدروس المسلحه الحديثه
الصراعات لتحسين قتالهم
تعبير
[موسيقى]
بدأت القوات في الوصول بدونها
نظائرها في مجمعات العالم
مضاد للطائرات ومضاد للصواريخ
تم تنفيذ الدفاع عن s-500 بنجاح و
اختبار عابر للقارات شديد
صاروخ باليستي سارمات مخطط له
التي في نهاية العام أول من هذا القبيل
المجمع سوف يذهب على رأس المال
حماية دونباس من النازيين الجدد
دعم السلام والأمن لنا
بعد كل بندقية
[موسيقى]
ل
تنسيقات اعتبر كالينينغراد أن من
كالينينغراد إلى برلين مائة وست ثوان
من كالينينغراد إلى باريس 200 ثانية أنت
مهتم بلندن 200 200
[موسيقى]
هو المعتدي
الذي فيه عقاب لا مفر منه أن يشاء
دمرت و
ما كنا
أغنية
أ
[موسيقى]
لا يستحق ذلك فقط